Hello friends.
Today, we will learn about light pollution.
Most of us are familiar with air, water, sound and land pollution...
...but did you know that light can also be a pollutant?
Light pollution is defined as any bad effect as a result of man-made or artificial lights.
In simple words, this means too much light.
Several species, including plants, animals and humans are badly affected by light pollution.
Um... now let's see the components of light pollution.
Sky glow.
This is when too many artificial lights cause the night sky to glow.
You can easily notice this when looking down at a well-lit city.
The sky above the city is too brightened and is harmful for all the species.
Light pollution dramatically reduces the visibility of stars.
In pristine areas, clouds appear black and blot out the stars.
In urban areas, cloud strongly enhanced sky glow.
Glare.
This is when a light that is very very bright...
...and often causes glare or visual discomfort when looking towards the light.
Oh no!